هل أنت مستعد
لقرص الطبل لعام 1905 الخاص بنا ، فالرجاء أن تنسى في الواقع
أسطوانة الطبول التي نعرف من الفائز
هو السؤال الحقيقي الذي يدور حول الكذبة التي
يحصل عليها الرئيس ترامب على اللقب الذي
قدمه المبلغون عن المخالفات رواية كاذبة
خرج المخبر بهذه
العبارة الرهيبة  حسنًا ،
كان المبلغون عن المخالفات غير دقيق للغاية في
الاحتيال على بلدنا لأن
المبلغين عن المخالفات كتب شيئًا
غير صحيح تمامًا أو على الأقل
خاطئًا تمامًا أو حتى أن
المبلغين أخطأوا كثيرًا مع
العديد من OHS PolitiFact يقولون إنهم وجدوا أكثر من
70 حالة من الرئيس ترامب
كرر ما اعتبروه  أن تكون
مدمنًا لأن تقرير المبلغين
عن المخالفات يتوافق
مع مكالمة الرئيس مع الرئيس الأوكراني ، وقد
اندهش الكثيرون من كيفية اختيار PolitiFact لبيئة غنية بالأهداف ،
حتى أن بعض الذين دعموا
الرئيس يقولون إنه كان كاذبًا خلقيًا
هذا الرجل هو  كاذب مرضي في بعض الأحيان
هو فنان BS كامل يلاحق بعض
النقاد  PolitiFact لإطلاق
صافرة على
المبلغين عن مخالفات الرئيس كذبة من الواضح أن الكلمة
الحقيقة في PolitiFact هي كذبة أيضًا أن
كذبة العنوان غير المرغوبة لهذا العام
جلبت الميمات مثل haha يمكنني الكذب أسرع مم
يمكنك التحقق من الحقائق والتهكم جيدًا عل
دونالد ترامب الحقيقي  لم تفز بجائزة
شخصية العام في مجلة TIME ، لكن على الأقل
لديك هذه المعلومات التي قدمها المبلغون عن المخالفات
الكثير من المعلومات غير الصحيحة ، هذه في
الواقع هي المرة الثالثة التي يكون فيها الرئيس
ترامب كذبة واحدة من العام ، مما يعني
أنه على الأقل لم يكن يكذب عندما  قال إن
هذا فوز كبير جدًا ، ولا
يمكننا تحمله بعد الآن.